okie dokie welcome to this video game
dr. Lecter that's a nice name grigor
grigor off and he has an IM here in the
textbook no GM so strong player so let's
get going i never played in before one
you form yeah playing it here to our
pieces to be too conservative i still
like to score points even though i'm out
of my regular openings then I'm playing
stuff I really don't know what I'm
playing here quite often is actually
some there are quite often lines that i
do recommend to to students of mine that
wonder that you like one efore
repertoire with with little study time
needed so i'm trying to play easy lines
let's say easy to play lines yep so
taking with the pawn there on my cheeks
and I Texas not bad maybe that's easier
just developing normally
they are probably 97 oh that looks like
a decent meals like bd7 but yeah dr.
lecture of obviously referring to
Hannibal Lecter from Silence of the
Lambs yeah he's going back with that
night yeah why not if i take it that
it's kind of slow but sure maybe just be
sure there for support the night a bit
now that looks quite okay simple to play
position
let's see how he yeah that's interesting
I actually expected that move that's
probably not a bad idea put the Queen
down let's activate the bishop here for
97 possibly Quincy five those kind of
this kind of setup okay 92 I know 92 I
can play Queen B 2 am taking b7 at the
end winning the exchange so I can play
the night to it some most natural square
k now is attacking a 593 here maybe 95
but ok that looks still quite quite
quite normal and good yeah okay that is
hanging now e5
i karouk d 190 xe5 we should be seven
that's probably bogus right okay let's
let let him to let him take them so yeah
the five corn is slightly weak but still
regulates a rook deform and rookie one
this doubling on the default shouldn't
be bad really c6 i think is really
strange why would he allow our cookie
six okay so he wants to trade him the
whole whole bunch okay i have i do that
Queen d4 he might really take be to who
I see it I see the point
so that should be okay yeah right pin
okay let's put it on d6 it's not deep
doing that much but I didn't really see
anything great group the eight Queen d2
is good for white I think strange what
is this night no doing night a 6mm
playing before then that should be ok
really so v5
tricky
I have to wonder if I should just go
back to de for them cc5 Queenie 400gm I
can go to see 400 actually quite good
yeah yep c5 Quincy for I'm just too slow
c5 Quincy was quite good what am i doing
if he is playing a slow move them
197 with the counter check that might
might be sufficient for him
96 f 4 that's a very handsome very loose
position time morning
played that really badly not using his
son is ISM to replate that far too risky
but I didn't use it at all check
Jeff just bad check no okay white
resigns yeah losing that is quite
embarrassing really because he did
everything to lose the game yeah moves
like c6 and so on so let's let's check
them I don't believe that one bit here
the setup would be fun maybe he's just
about okay but 424 is 6 p-6 I cannot
believe it b6 so this is may be wrong
this should be too maybe this is what
the engine is giving 98 and then F then
something like f form
just have a pawn I really thought it is
better than that just have a pawn for
wine but the line that the engine is
giving is quite funny i think this
should just just be really good for
night this is this year these are things
that I kind of saw as this night is just
completely ridiculous bees at times but
yeah maybe if yeah this is maybe holder
looks really bad but it may be holds
just just always have a powerful mind
it's not more yeah a force maybe not a
good idea this is this is definitely
wrong this Queenie 7r at the end is the
problems i'm also be five what's this
then queens the six wins ok this is this
is something that that that i did not
see at all so and this was what was the
key point limiting his night back there
yeah this is no good for black knight to
e7 night to d5 yeah not a game i really
should lose round here i think it's
probably about equal or so but I really
don't understand this is this thing
there c 6 and so on I don't believe that
but it seems to be so fairly okay the
computer never goes above have a pawn
for white I really thought it is worse
but doesn't seem to be that terrible it
seems to hold even those clumsy night
maneuvers it seems to hold my bishop is
not that great as well as looking at the
c6 but i thought this before and so on
and would um yeah put and learn it again
no a difficult position it's really
difficult than a thought I thought white
is just bad of it it's not so easy this
should be two probably is an improvement
if he has to go back there now something
like this f1 c5 and then we had that we
had that but even that just have a pawn
at least if you can't believe the engine
there okay well thanks for watching